[Musique]
ils ont mis un coup de sirène je connais
déjà hors la loi
on a surfé quoi de 3 eur puis à 4
policiers qui sont arrivés ils ont tous
fait sortir de l'eau mais on n'a pas
attendu longtemps avant de retourner
dans le code
[Musique]
oh
on va pouvoir les faire ses courses sur
les champs-elysées rue sainte catherine
à bordeaux et sur des centaines de
kilomètres de plages de sable fin font
pas confiance aux élus le faut de plus
on l'aimé prisme et on leur donne pas
donc ils ont bourré l'opportunité de
démontrer que nous sommes capables de
pouvoir organiser
[Musique]
on
bon
[Musique]
où
mon
[Musique]
e
bonjour c'est aussi tout un tas de
petites entreprises mais qui peuvent
avoir jusqu'à 5 6 salariés saisonniers
ils font partie de l'économie du
littoral il ya des gens qui choisissent
leur destination pour venir surfer donc
tout ça c'est une économie fragile et
que et qui sera en péril est vraiment en
péril si on dément à la fin du mois de
juin
[Musique]
où
moore
[Musique]
peux pas vous dire qu'on arrivera calme
et la discipline et à arriver à contenir
l'envié et la passion de tout le monde
j'espère que ça se passera
[Musique]